[Music]
[Applause]
the mass singer is back the celebs are
bigger than ever and the clues are even
harder welcome to ETS Massacre
after-show I'm Charlie O'Keeffe and I'm
Deidre Behar listen we're here to guide
you through all the singing and all the
secrets think of us as your singing
detectives yup we'll be revealing all
the stars as they come along throughout
the season and we'll be giving you
hard-hitting theories on all the clues
and each episode let's get right into it
on the season 2 premiere we met eight
masked celebs and sadly two went home
the first the end
[Applause]
Johnny weird Johnny we're okay I gotta
be honest I think I predicted this one
from the gift I think we both predicted
this way I was pretty confident I was
surprised obviously when he took off the
head but not shocked
right right right you know the the clues
in the clue package were very telling
the Swan and the glittery costumes and I
mean how many Olympic puns can you fit
in there were so many I mean some of my
favorite on top of the pyramid for years
he's been going for the gold and I
thought this skateboard was an
interesting clue because all we were
supposed to take that from that was
skate skater right an ice skater right
and I initially thought maybe
skateboarder like a Tony Hawk or
somewhere but now the customs are too
fabulous it had to be Johnny Weir come
on and Robin and Jenny were actually
right on this one they guessed it was
Johnny and they got it right and they
got it right and you know what I took to
YouTube and I actually saw Johnny has
performed to this song before he has a
cage Gaga fans so I think the writing
was kind of on the wall job well done
Johnny completely better next time
next up we said goodbye to the ice cream
[Applause]
okay ninja ninja very unexpected I did
not guess this one I felt like I should
have gotten a YouTube person but I did
not guess a ninja yes you want the
YouTube generation yeah I think
originally I was leaning towards on
makeup artists an influencer or maybe
someone like a Logan Paul or a Jake Paul
who loved the limelight loved performing
but then as I started watching and it
was like the clue package said no one
ever thought I'd amount to anything and
my parents didn't quite understand what
I did for a living then it's like okay
you play video games as a kid no one
thought it would ever turn into anything
and surprise ninjas like a Mega Million
and I thought the song choice was
definitely nodding towards a younger
person old town road song of the summer
it obviously made sense that it was
someone of a younger generation of
course and if you're a fortnight fan you
recognize those fortnight dances going
on in the background for sure so with
the egg and the ice cream cone gone we
were left to keep guessing who's
underneath the remaining six costumes
take a look at the butterfly
[Music]
all right listen I grew up with
Destiny's Child I know my Beyonce I know
my Kelly and I know my Michelle that has
got to be Michelle Williams without a
doubt that is Michelle Williams I am
willing to put money on it I am 100%
convinced I am a great mean we're in
agreement on this one yeah we're both
putting money which I will happen what
gave it away for you so first of all the
voice I know the voice when I hear the
voice
second of all the costume in and of
itself butterfly it represents rebirth
and we know Michelle my sweet angel
Michelle because she has gone through a
tough year she split from her fiance she
entered treatment and at the end of the
day I think she's a woman who is a
natural gifted born performer and the
butterfly represents rebirth and she's
just here to soar no social media
thought a few different ways on this one
there was a lot of Michelle Williams out
there but also taraji P Henson which I
thought was very interesting now for
sure not to Raji P Henson I adore taraji
I think she's a little busy and
preoccupied at the moment working on
other shows and like 7,000 different
movies over
I think the clues are just too strong in
the Michelle Arena to lean towards
anyone else I think one of those biggest
clues was the praying she talked a lot
about the gospel singer and not hit it
on the mark that is 100% Michelle
Williams and next up we were thing I'm a
shocked by the thing of a jig take a
look
[Music]
hard for me to guess this one at first
but then once I hit the Google I started
to piece together this has got to be
Wayne brake completely do you think it's
Wayne Brady I think it's Wayne Brady
I've seen him on Broadway actually in
kinky boots when he was in that about
two years ago and I could recognize that
voice 100%
I mean it's so interesting you bring up
kinky boots because I think when people
think of Wayne Brady you think of let's
make a deal and you think of like comedy
and stand-up special I don't necessarily
associate him with with Broadway but the
number four was in his clue package and
if you take a look on what is it
playbill.com he has done four runs on
Broadway so that's a huge clue and then
also the outfit that the thingamajig is
wearing it looks like Wayne Brady hand
designed that himself I bet you he has a
replica of that in his own closet the
guy loves platy lives for plaid so I
feel like there's there's a lot of clues
that are very heavy leaning Wayne Brady
I think even we saw a candle and that
clue package it was number four on a
cupcake yeah did a little digging there
as well he has four Daytime Emmy Awards
which could be nodding at that for
Broadway runs for Daytime Emmy Awards I
think all clues are pointing towards the
man in the suit being Wayne Brady loved
it
alright get ready to rock your bones
over this one meet the skeleton
this one was hard man I don't know no
shots at this one really I I was really
struggling I thought can obviously made
some great guesses he was convinced this
was his idol Martin Short I can see that
in a few ways I know you dug a bit
deeper with the Christmas movies what do
you think of that yeah so Christmas was
a clue in the clue package and I don't
really associate Martin Short with
Christmas although I do love watching
father of the bride open holidays he has
done three Christmas themed movies so
that would absolutely make sense
the other big clue of note is the second
fiddle mm-hmm and it's probably someone
who has played the sidekick many times
Martin Short you know he has played
Steve Martin's sidekick quite often um
and also I did some some digging on this
he was in the show Mulaney in 2014 and
actually a reporter asked him you know
are you ever annoyed playing second
fiddle to someone and Martin Short just
always so diplomatic and lovely he goes
I just love being an actor so I just
love being able to do what I get to do I
don't really care if it's the first in
command or the seventh you know and
there were some clues that I couldn't
quite pin I don't think you got them as
well we saw a ring of keys in the clue
package as well as the iconic phrase
party on right so then did you start
thinking Dana Carvey I did so that could
be an option there I think the judges
might have thrown it around as well but
Kenna set on Martin Short and for the
moment until we get more clues I'm
saying Martin Short as well I'm saying
I'm Martin Short third yes all right
let's move on to the ladybug
[Music]
again pretty stumped on this one I was
stumped but I did a little more digging
I mean that voice definitely sounds
familiar but I think we both struggled
pinning it to a specific person the clue
package gave away a few things we saw a
TV show set which was very interesting
born into the limelight was the biggest
who are you thinking in terms of reality
families okay so my first guess was
brandy Cyrus someone who has been born
into this famous family maybe has kind
of lived in the shadow of her sister for
a minute also similarly famous family
and southern there's a southern accent
there Jamie Lynn Spears totally right
plausible plausible I think it could be
Jamie Lynn I'm not set on the accents I
think they might be using them to throw
us off a little bit this season so I'm
not painting anyone to something
specific because it might be a voice
changing mic at this point it could be
so who are you leaning towards at the
moment I'm leaning towards Kelly
Osbourne oh that's it I think it could
be Kelly I did a little digging on
YouTube found some videos of first
singing that voice sounds very very
familiar she's grown up in the limelight
obviously her family had a reality show
as well as a few other clues hinting
towards the Osborne family my mom Liam
on me alright we have a spinning wheel
which was part of her second round with
the Osborne family game show we saw a
bridge that had to do with the Sydney
Harbour Bridge nearby - Osborne
Australia as well as a bat and a ham the
ham I had to point out this one so funny
during season 1 of the show Sharon
Osbourne actually threw a ham out there
nice right it's a little subtle but it
makes sense I'm pinning it on Kelly
Osbourne if it's truly a southern star
then it can't be Kelly but Kelly could
be throwing us for a loop and putting on
a good accent so I kind of buy into that
right now alright next let's see if you
can figure out who let those out while
they're out hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo
[Applause]
all right this is someone who is
obviously very swaggy we're led to
believe that this is someone in the
sports world there were so many
references to you know a Super Bowl ring
and and the pigskin and the Friday Night
Lights but then as soon as the
Rottweiler took the stage my goodness
Mike Nicole said one of the best vocals
we have ever heard on this show since
the show started completely I mean the
voice was there there's no question
about it this person is a singer and if
they aren't a singer and they need to
get on it and give us a number-one hit
because amazing amazing vocals and it's
definitely making it a lot harder to pin
it on someone connect it to football or
sports that we've never heard perform I
think it could be so the song is
interesting maneater it's a song from
you know decades past I don't
necessarily think a younger person would
kick this song so I'm gonna think it's
someone like New Kids on the Block it
could be like a Jordan Knight or a Joey
McIntyre but then I started thinking
like could it be like a Randy Jackson I
could see it I definitely think the
boyband swagger was there they have such
a specific way Pacific Way of yakking on
the stage it was definitely a part of
that and I think it could be a break out
boy band member oh god I would love to
see some Jordan Knight up there
and of course lastly the tree but
specifically a Christmas tree
[Applause]
all right hands down the hardest one of
the night completely I have no gases
which I possess and when I have some
names to throw out there but the more I
watch it back the more I think I am
completely wrong okay did you get any
specific clues out of it okay so the
number 30 has significance something
important they showed it for a while and
that's really the biggest clue we got
out of that entire package right so
here's a couple things we know it's
someone who like apparently likes jazz
jazz someone who has an affinity for
cooking and someone who is like sad it
actually makes definitely an emotional
clue package it's someone who feels like
they only get there at their moment of
glory during the holidays and for the
rest of the year they feel kind of
tossed to the side I Love Lucy Chabert
and she is my best guest because she is
a fixture on the Hallmark Channel she
does some of the Christmas movies and of
course who could forget the jingle bell
rock scene from Mean Girls so I don't
know if maybe like I feel pushed aside
or tied to one thing like Christmas is
maybe sort of a metaphor like I feel
like I'm always just gonna be asked
about Mean Girls for the rest of them
okay what do you think I mean I had
Candace Cameron Bure or Melissa Joan
Hart down there as well they've both
done a lot of Christmas movies hallmark
in lifetime they go for fuller house
older house exactly they've both done
some cooking shows so that can be tight
in there as well but it's just
definitely someone who's been on TV
around the holidays cooking jazz singing
there's a lot going on but we're missing
something with this one 1,000% and I am
so curious because I don't think I've
ever actually heard Lacey Chabert sing I
tried going on YouTube I tried googling
Lacey's singing nothing really came up
and this person has an extremely soulful
voice totally so it sounds like someone
who has like been raised with musical
theater or some sort of a background and
I think we'll get more clues as the
week's go on and hopefully we'll be able
to crack this one as well the mayhem on
the master singer is just getting
started next week we'll meet eight
brand-new contestants in costume and
Charlie and I will be here doing our
best detective work to uncover who's
behind the mask leave us a comment with
your best and craziest theories and
tweet us so we can all guess together
I'm Charlie O'Keeffe
and I'm at Deidre Behar we'll see you
next week
[Applause]